we want to give you an idea of what he
went through first of all he was brought
here with his hands tied and was told to
stand here he says then that a soldier
put the gun underneath his arms and told
him just to stand there as he used this
as a sniper's position and you can still
see the spent cartridges
on the floor now if we walk through to
another part of the house you will see
where we've got to be very careful
negotiating this because there's a lot
of bricks and blocks first of all I want
to show you where another sniper's
position was set up how the soldiers
knocked through a hole in the wall and
you can see the view out of there
they've got a view down to the camp so
of course the question then becomes how
did the soldiers manage to get into this
house and it becomes very clear when you
turn around here
they came through the neighbors and
before that the neighbors before that so
they pushed their way through this house
through the wall
and I'm now standing in next door
neighbor's house and that is how they
made their way through a lot of the
streets here in Janine they've got the
cover so people can't see them out in
the open but they make sure that they're
protected by not being in an area
where they can be spotted by snipers